everyone welcome back today I'm going to
be giving you another guitar tip today's
tip is about tuning
[Music]
so most guitarists today are using these
really convenient little electronic
tuners they clip on to the headstock of
the guitar and they display the note
you're playing and they tell you if
you're sharp or flat they're super
convenient and I've always thought they
look like little James Bond devices so
if you're a beginner guitar player and
you don't have the hearing skills yet to
tune the guitar by here i really suggest
getting one of these but if you're an
experienced guitar player and you want
to go to the next level today I'm going
to challenge you to put this aside and
to start tuning by here
[Music]
now in order to tune my ear we're gonna
have to learn how to start hearing what
are called beats and a beat is a
acoustical phenomenon that occurs when
two notes are very close together but
not quite and it creates this sort of
whoa whoa whoa mome effect and if we're
hearing beats that means we're not in
tune so let's let's hear some beats here
[Music]
you hear that so if we're ever hearing
that sound something's not quite right
listen to what happens now if I change
one of the notes until they match it's
going to sound something like whoa whoa
whoa wha and it'll flatline and when the
notes sound pure I'm in tune so let's
hear it
[Music]
there don't feel too bad if you're
having a hard time hearing the beats
it's a new sound for many people but as
you tune this has become more and more
apparent now I was just tuning with
harmonics and that's one way to tune but
today I'm gonna recommend a different
system which i think is a bit more
reliable one of the most common ways of
tuning the guitar by here is the fifth
fret method and I think it has some
advantages and some disadvantages one of
the advantages is that the notes are
unison so it's very easy to tell if
they're not in tune the disadvantage of
this system is if you make one error the
error just gets worse and worse and by
the time you end up at the low E you can
end up with an entirely different e so
for those who don't know the system
works like this there's you play the
first string E and then the fifth fret
on the second string then you play the
open B and the fourth fret on the third
string that's the only string that's the
exception
the rest are fifth fret he played G and
then the fifth fret of the fourth string
you play D the fifth fret of the fifth
string a fifth fret of the string so
like I said it's pretty easy to use but
often I see people use this method and
then they end up still out of tune I'd
like to recommend my system which i
think is a bit more reliable I'm going
to teach you how to tune the entire
guitar to the first string E and this is
so reliable because regardless of if
ease in tune or not you will be
completely in tune with yourself and all
the strings will be cross-checked with
one string
meaning you're much more likely to sound
good the way it works is we start with
an open E string the first string and
then we play the fifth fret on the
second string so that part's the same as
the other tuning system but next we play
the third fret
on the first string and the open G okay
that one sounded good
now we're gonna play the open E and then
the fourth string second fret make a
match okay next we play the open E and
the fifth string seventh fret and lastly
the first string and the sixth string E
now this e and this e are two octaves
apart that's a great distance and some
people find it difficult to tell if
those match so it's very helpful at this
stage then to play the first string e
the fourth string E on the second fret
and the low E simultaneously or
arpeggiated that should sound totally
pure because they're all e I then like
to check a couple different notes so if
I play the first string E and a 7th fret
harmonic on the fifth string a
[Music]
that's a good check and then if I play
the open B string and the seventh fret
of the sixth string e that sounds pretty
good I can hear the distance between
those notes a bit easier because they're
unison okay so now for a very important
lesson regardless of whatever tuning
system you prefer when you're done with
your tuning system you're still aren't
finished tuning yeah I recommend playing
a chord and the chord you pick should
not be random
you should play a chord which is in the
key in what you're playing so if I'm
playing in G major I would roll the G
major chord and you can roll it slowly
so you can really hear the notes
listening very carefully that sounds
good so I think I'm good to go
however sometimes you'll you'll go
through your tuning system and when you
play a chord pretty nasty sound two
things don't lie Shakira's hips and
courts if a chord sounds bad you're not
in tune if a chord sounds really good
and beautiful
you're probably in tune so what I would
recommend if you hear a sort of nasty
sounding chord is to roll it very slowly
and listen
of that one there's the problem see if
you can fix it
keep guessing
sounds pretty good so I always check
with a cord and I use the whatever the
the tonic chord is and the key in which
I'm playing okay so I hope you're going
to accept my challenge to start tuning
by ear and using that electronic tuner
less every time you pick up your
instrument start with tuning it might be
a bit difficult at first and if you're
really in a pickle check with an
electronic tuner but each time you do it
your ear is going to get sharper and
you'll be able to listen to those beats
and really detect them the more you do
it the easier it gets if you do this
you'll find that your ear will get
sharper and sharper and what's better
than a sharp ear for a musician so
thanks for watching guys if you haven't
already hit the subscribe button because
I'm gonna be releasing more videos
giving you guitar tips I'm gonna be
releasing more videos in my introducing
series where I teach you all about rare
and sort of forgotten beautiful plucked
instruments from the past you can also
check out my patreon page for a patron
only content and yeah thanks for
watching
[Music]